welcome to ninjalah this is Angela this
is a game that's like a I don't even
describe it this game it's about ninjas
and in jawless hi my name is markiplier
this video sponsored by Angela a
free-to-play game that you can get
through the link in the description
below they were kind enough to sponsor
me in this video
what does happening stop use ninja gum
to unleash skills and do battle with
your foes the flow of battle first keep
an eye out for drones this is a drone
find them and destroy as many as you can
destroying drones will increase your
energy interesting accumulate s energy
interesting and your gum will grow
stronger fascinating you can crop you
can craft big weapons from company
enhance your weapons to defeat your foes
win with an Ebola alright nice nice nice
interesting it's a little Ethan ok well
I've got a bad case of main character
syndrome pretty much all the time so I
think I gotta go with whatever the
default was then an energetic young boy
fit to be the hero of a kids manga he
hates losing and always wants to stand
out from the crowd playing or battling
he always gives it his all I'm not
saying that is me but that really sounds
like me all right skin eyes brown brown
is brown hair no I just did here looking
good
ok ok I've learned how to walk I've
locked on target
you'll never get me that's it
what have I done I'm a box wire my box I
meant to hit someone yeah all right it's
this button alright is this my s energy
B is Jim alright
that's charge okay Bam Bam Bam Bam
oh hell yeah oh this is gonna take some
all right he's in charge how do you do
the gum that's how you do I'm a box
interesting interesting interesting okay
I've got it yeah I feel pretty confident
that I could go into multiplayer battles
now this game has been out for 13
minutes I would fully believe that there
are kids that are already experts at
this oh hey oh hey this my house on a
roof Wow
is that my cat oh I don't know what that
slime demon is on the top of the Shelf
there but oh my god
all right little cosmetics do I have
anything battle equipment a big stick
okay avatar I don't think I have
anything do I
I do oh my goodness that looks good
I do have stuff that's shocking eyepatch
nerd glasses yes sure for the broken
nose I'm definitely gonna get a Farnese
definers oh it's the game music
[Music]
oh that's not the music I just picked
all right I'm gonna go battle are you
guys are about to see beans the likes of
which you have never experienced all
right I'm ready oh yeah okay so we we
hit fit what did I just do we hit those
things we turn into boxes blink sneak up
on people
cuz I'm a ninja Oh while I was doing
some funky moves what is with the
disappearing that's cool
this guy doesn't dies i am i doing it
wrong
I expect to crush that's what I'm
expecting oh well there we go
okay we're going in me me it's me I
think I'm pretty sure it's me I don't
know how to play oh there we go we're
going apparently you whatever your name
is
ah what back
what happened I'm gummed ow why do you
have a beyblade how'd you get that okay
uh okay you over there I'm gonna get you
yeah how do these people have amazing
items like that whoa I missed Oh No
where am I oh no no please oh I'm a I'm
poop now my poop oh no oh God wait okay
there's some kind of like parry system
that I'm not super privy to oh that's
not good
oh that's not good oh that's not good
ah that's not good I think I got ganged
up on hey you have a giant what what is
that this game's real tough it's not
that I'm bad at it it's just too tough
oh my goodness am I supposed to be
pressing something because I'm not but
I'm trying but I'm not pressed nothing
okay this is this is it this is the one
this one's for all the beans and in no
mistake for you yeah yes yes yes yes yes
no no no no this way yes I did a thing
guys yeah I destroyed them I don't know
if I destroyed them but it felt like I
destroyed him
what no that's not good I don't know
what's happening
am i winning oh why did her thinking I
guess I might just be mashing buttons
but it feels super nice all right good
jaden kicked your butt before I'll do it
again okay this is interesting
oh where am I
oh yes oh I don't know what's happening
here
um man I'm gone I've been a pond what
does that mean all right don't you worry
guys a solid fifth
knows eel plus a okay here we go all
right this is what we do looking like
this oh I really wasted that that was a
real big waste
I am gonna lose alright I guess we
stopped here looking I'm ready
I'm going to the standby dojo so I can
hone my skills I'm a box I forgot how to
swing I don't know what what how do you
do that I'm not a hundred percent sure
what I'm doing to do the behind thing
for him like teleporting behind
something to do with like turning when
you hit him Wow alright so I'm pretty
sure that you know just having a bigger
weapon is good
dang yeah oh it does it goes with the
movement button okay interesting so like
say for example I'm holding right I'll
go right around him left around him
right I don't think up is a thing but
definitely right and left around so you
can move see I'm learning guys I'm
learning I'm learning all the tricks
devastation thy name is markiplier I'm
about to ruin everyone's day what did I
just do oh that that's a new move I
didn't know I could do that well that's
interesting weird I didn't know that was
a thing I'm learning all the moves
alright we're about to go in let's do it
[Applause]
all right let's do it
ninjalah woof
[Applause]
[Music]
whoa where'd you go where'd you go
where'd you go where'd you go
come on no no no no not like this No
that's my kill oh no you stole that you
stole that you stole that from me
how could you do that to me I'm so
handsome Oh
what happens why does it just go sailing
right by I'm a box you'll never know I
it's me
I was the box oh no no no no no what
what what does it mean what does the
peri mean am I just bad luck what why is
this suddenly stop don't you dare no no
no stop
you are gonna go go no hit the button
hit the super but no stop oh can I do
nothing can I do nothing can I do
nothing is nothing what I can do
oh yeah I don't know what I did but it
sounded no not over here why am i over
here now
whoa no kit my special I want my special
so badly Boosh I missed oh where am I
going
stop it who fired the blue-eyes White
Dragon I am NOT doing well in case
anyone was wondering I'm doing um not
well
why don't we sail past some whereas in
training I would go up and fight them
you know that whole thing I feel like
something's off a little bit I feel like
something so I should be better no
that's up that's a hey hey I'm box why
do you get a dragon that's not cool you
can't hit me
ah missed me whoa why is there everyone
here what why can I didn't do nothing
can I please do something can I do
something hit somebody I don't know and
then there I go no I hit someone but
they didn't K oh oh
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm not crying I'm not crying is the
thing I'm not crying I'm sweating from
the sheer amount of work that I put in I
put in the work I do it I put in the
work and that's what I do you know I
always put in the work
that's what I do I'm all about it's all
about the grind it's all about the grind
I got something new what did I get
battle equipment that must be the
problem it's just that I got the wrong
item that oh I have other items you know
when I when I swing swung I swing swung
hard that's what I know
you know yes yes I like this one it just
looks cool I don't know I don't know
what the do idea what the difference is
between any of these all right let's go
for it going to the standby dojo gonna
test out my new gun who's gonna say I'm
a box oh that's one P oh but it's so
slow what
[Music]
interesting interesting interesting okay
it's gonna take some getting used to
because I feel like this weapon isn't
the kind of the spammy weapon which is
really what I am good at like I'm good
at that okay that stuns people so okay
so I can stun them and then follow up
and then I got some rocket oh sure great
mimic my damn oh yes baby interesting
very very interesting Oh excellent
this might turn out okay after all okay
so there's some combos you can do with
this definitely boom Oh what interesting
hmm
oh hi there are we going in okay this
new weapon is gonna do me no good and
I'm never gonna be able to survive hey
what's up hey how you doing hey how you
doing hey what's going on hey dude
alright here we go
off ha
Wow who did that
Wow whoa wolf off hey whoa wait I can't
do anything why is it just sometimes I
can do nothing
oh where am I going no this is opposite
of what I want
Oh oh god how are people running away
like that that's what I want to know
there must be some some secret maneuver
that I'm not privy to okay or I can do
nothing what are you doing who are you
and why are you here
these kill stealers these these
opportunists huh don't kill me don't
leave me alone yeah how are they going
in the ground that's what I need to know
oh that's not good Wow
no that's unfair that's unfair can I
please do something can I please do
something okay all right Oh
bar right sure yep I am stuck can i I
it's like cheating of everything I've
ever done and not letting me do any of
it what no that's not what I wanted to
do okay it works though did it yeah it's
too easy to do like the the AoE stun
thing I mean it's nice but now I don't
always want to do it oh that's not what
I wanted to do but you invisible was
that person invisible
ow ow okay behaves missed me
now you must kiss me
ah no now now hey but I'm in fourth so
that's a thing that's intro hey bud how
are you doing bud I'm thinking that this
spinning attack it actually doesn't do
that much damage which is unfortunate
let us go yes let's go all right you do
get points for that so that's good
oh please I want to get in the fight
want to do something right can I please
do that can I please do this I don't
care if it's opportunist oh my god
my rocket is ready my rocket is ready oh
no let me let me rock it let me please
oh did it not rock it he used up my
rocket but it didn't oh but it didn't
rock it Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
it's fine
that's not bad it's not bad but I don't
think I like the big hammer cuz it's I
I'm sponsored by gung-ho and Angela for
this video
you can download in gel on your Nintendo
switch for free it's not a pay to win
game on the optional in game cosmetics
which will update when the seasons
release every eight to ten weeks check
it out for yourself I'm sponsored
[Music]